We make assumptions about people all the time. It's not necessarily a bad thing,
but how often are we actually right about the assumptions we make and how often
are we right about the assumptions other people make about us to find out.
We decided to put someone in the hot seat and have 100 strangers,
rate them one to 100 based on various levels of first impression in doing so we
would hopefully be able to see how different ways of communicating could
drastically change the way we perceive others. Welcome to one-to-one hundred.
Hi, my name is Julia and 20.
What would you rate yourself average to good, like kind of in between seven,
10 and a half at 70 or 75,
this first group of people will only be able to look at you kind of
nervous. I've never like been graded.
Um, can she show her ears?
Okay, cool.
He wants to like a better fit for me, like a a hundred slides difficulty,
or like a model she's flawless. And then I was like, well, you know,
I can't just go on looks. I gotta look at other stuff.
And this is the most shallow thing. I Dr. Five points.
Cause she had some Wal-Mart in the background. I don't know if that's my vibe.
She wasn't really my type. She didn't look like a plain regular type of.
[Inaudible].
It was weird to kind of like people were like looking at me.
I've never kind of experienced being like on a, like a display like that.
I guess. I don't know.
Julie has given me fashion fun and quirkiness and I'm loving it and
she's absolutely stunning.
And then one of the most beautiful people you could have chosen,
she's super pretty. And she's also like not afraid to be herself.
And she also sounds like really funny.
Like I just listened to a part of one of her videos and she was telling like a
funny story and that just made her even more pretty, but I'm going to cry.
There's some nice, obviously she's very like.
I see some of her posts where she's advocating for black lives matters.
I'm privileged and I will never understand what it's like to be black.
That's what's most important to me sort of is that sometimes people can look
extremely beautiful or attractive until they open their mouth.
It's a brave thing to do, especially in class. And you would see backlash.
It just makes it like.
I did like my own special rating between one and a hundred,
150 and pop track.
If she was obviously I gave her a fit because she's beautiful.
The rest was like bonus points, 10 points for having a cool pose.
10 more points for, you know, talking about black lives matter.
Everybody else was saying that she was beautiful. I don't know.
I didn't really find her or anything.
It's not the type of girl I usually like go for.
So we can speak about your score. Um,
what about her Instagram led to you giving that score?
I did not realize that it was one to 100 that you thought it was a scale out of
10. Yeah. Especially by societal standards. She's incredibly attractive,
but I'm not too fond of like perfection.
There's people are so nice. I was looking to cry. They're so sweet.
I love how they were like really putting the importance on,
not just like the outside, but like on the inside. There's some, some kind.
We are going to head over to the next section now, which is the phone call.
Hi Julia. Okay. Hi. How are you? Where are you from?
So I'm from Vancouver. Oh, cool. Don't they have a good don't.
You'll have to a Naval syrup. Oh my God.
I love your energy. Yeah. Hang on. I'm here to have a good time.
I like hearing your voice. I'm trying to guess how old you are. I'm 20
or what about it? Like makes us think that was, I talk really fast.
I've been twice. So I don't know. I've always used a blabber and I hate it,
but like that's just me Canadian bacon. Is that it's ham,
but then why is it like hogging and making it so misleading?
Like it's actually in Canada too. I have no idea. I'm a pescatarian, so. Okay.
Nice. Amazing. Are you from I'm from Mississippi. Oh,
okay. Well we do. So I'm like a model and like a musicians and a student.
So I kind of like, I'm all over the place. So I was in New York,
then I was in LA and I went to Turkey and I went to India.
I just recently graduated. I didn't employ the current light bulb.
Well, the world we're all in employed at some point, I suppose. So.
Yeah, definitely. Um, what else? Even food.
Favorite food. I'm not really picky. Any hobbies?
Oh man. Well, I'm taking five classes right now, so.
No free time.
Make the world a better place.
Hm I'm a Christian. So like, I believe that like being a light in the world,
like wherever I go, it's holding the door open or smiling.
I can change someone's whole life. Oh yeah. That's awesome.
Hey man, I can already tell even without, without no face cams.
Yo great personality. That's all right. That's two minutes.
I dunno. I felt that she was just a really down to earth person,
but in that two minutes, I mean, I wasn't able to see any of her flaws, right?
Like her voice. Wasn't going to do anything for me in that way.
It's like a 62 off someone's voice and a two-minute conversation to me is like
pretty high.
Um, obviously she seemed like a really nice approachable person,
but without seeing someone,
I can only assume really that she falls somewhere around the normal curve.
You know, I enjoy talking to her.
So that's why she scored more than the 50th percentile.
My instinct tells me that was probably the lowest, but I could be wrong,
but that's kind of like where I'm thinking.
I am a little insecure in how I talk.
I just hate listening to myself talk and I talk really fast and sometimes I like
mess up my words and that kind of stuff.
So I guess I can be kind of like self-conscious about that. I talk a lot.
This one videos on so you can just stay on camera.
Hey, how are you? Okay. Oh, is this an actual person? Oh
God. Hi. I'm Julia. Hi there. I'm from Spain.
Maybe the accent. Yeah. I love you.
That's a beautiful accent. What's your sign Aries.
Ooh, fire queen. I'm a Virgo, but I'm a Sagittarius moon. Um,
any hobbies?
Um, all I do is study. I'm going to be a pre-med student over there.
I'm part of a dance to you on a singer songwriter. What about you?
Play me a song really quick. Um, can I see it?
You look so beautiful by the way. I love your hair. Like your short hair.
I wish I could pull it off. I cannot be like, Oh girl, you could work it.
So what kind of doctor or like medical question do you want.
I'm thinking about, uh, being a cardiothoracic surgeon,
a neurological surgeon or both preferably Alrighty.
That's two minutes. He is a very pretty so. And you know, she,
uh, asked me about myself. Like honestly,
think that was a really sweet aspect of her making me feel.
So that's also a plus.
She was really nice and I think would push it up the score more was that she was
interested in like my dad's team. And um,
when I mentioned K-pop.
I got a little more comfortable, I think,
because I talk with my hands and I use gestures and facial expressions. Um,
so I feel like maybe it went a little better because I could kind of like be,
you know, show like expressions and all that kind of stuff.
Thinking back to every section and how you felt it went.
If you can guess the average score within three points of it,
then you went a hundred dollars.
Okay. Let me just, I'm going to go 83.
[Inaudible].
Oh, really.
Scoring someone from one to 100. Obviously. That's really hard to do,
especially if you can't see the person.
Just so you know, this is against everything I stand for. I'm here.
I'm I'm in a committed relationship. Like I was like, this is
what I was like. No, no, no. I Dr. Five points for Walmart. Okay.
The average for that round was 86.
Oh shoot. Well, I'm just a Savage.
I feel bad, but
I would actually have to get to know the person for that person to be like more
attractive.
Attractiveness is really subjective.
I think ultimately these numbers are kind of just numbers and it really just
matters like how you feel about yourself and how you portray yourself.
And I think the other thing is that, you know, when we're at evaluating people,
we're always afraid of offending them. But you know, ultimately I,
I think it's important to be pragmatic and, and to, um,
score how you feel they should be scored.
Overall. It was so funny,
interesting to kind of get to interact with these people and see how they,
how they saw me, because I'm always like wondered,
like what do I look like from somebody else's perspective?
And if you can meet ourselves from somebody else's eyes, that'd be so cool,
but also not putting too much stress on that because I can't change that.
I'm gonna keep being me.
Okay.